allez
moteur ti je t'amène sur des gens
tranquille
is le gros rocher qui est à gauche du
cadre ouais tu descends du rocher dans
la même ligne vers le FU il y a des gens
la pointe ouais
exactement même pas
mal le
matin dou
attention à l'ombre qui arrive de la
droite pour l'instant ça
encore
vont
l' qui va rentrer attends je ok d'accord
ok ok ok ok on a l'ombre ok ok ok on sa
on y arrive
tranquillou
et là tu restes comme ça et je vais
t'amener des gens qui vont laver avec
les trucs sur la
tête
la poussière je sais voilà il rentre en
bas du
cadre ah ils ont peur les
pauvres
ah c'est
relou tu fasses la même chose mais très
serré sur eux je pense j'arrive on va
prre un autre alliment dès que tu as
sorti
ok on va voir ça 10000 fois s du club ça
va
g vas-y on on va all reprendre de plus
loin ok ok ok allez
C on avance on va le l à gauche
merci quand tu me dis que j j'y vais
tranquille ou oui
doucementismite je sais pas si toi tu
restes ou tu PES comme tu veux je sais
pas reste dessus je t'amène les autres
c'est ça ou tu vas dessus reste dessus
d'accord Bou pas tu là euh je pense
qu'on vibre là ouais
ça laisse tomber on est très loin là
laisse tomber ouais on est loin là Fran
ou mon point d'accord ben je bien en
faire plus près mais j'ai peur qu'elle
parte ça attends laisse tomber
avec fait là où recherche
tourne tu ve les prendre comment là tu
veux que
ça déjà c'est que déjà ce qui est bien
c'est qu'elle s'occupe pas de
nous rigole se Mar
le
tappul reste là reste là bon tant pis
ouais on est
loin ce que tu vas faire tu vas te
rapprocher en marchant par la remontant
le remontant le la rivière plutôt moi je
remonterai tu
vois
montrer plus plus loin d'elle tu vois
plus alors attend coup écouter ce
que je monter plus loin d'elle par la
droite quete pere moins
de comme tu veux c'est joli C c'est joli
c'est comme en tout cas voilà c'est joli
ça de loin
c'est continue alors ça c'est bien c'est
bien ça voilà voilà voilà ça c'est bien
ça voilà voilà elle tape le truc voilà
ça c'est génial voilà voilà ça c'est
bien
voilà on t'envoie de l'eau là je reçois
de l'eau là me f-toi tu do avoir de
l'eau sur l'objectif qui je reçois la
sur la
main un peu bas la p tu es un peu bas tu
c'est
bin ah yes
poussière c'est s
objectif c'est toi tu es un peu bas Fran
tu prends de l'eau tu prends de la voil
voilà voil voilà voilà cétait pour avoir
les premiers ouais mais toi il y a rien
eu dans l'objectif il rien la poussire
poussière tuas eu mais non c'est sûr je
voyaison pas
trop
jolière
tu peux dzoomer pe vers l'arrière tu vas
voir toute tout lî avec tout plein de
gens qui travaillent pe joli non je pas
j'arrive j'arrive
j'arriveir tellement de truc je
m'inquiète un
peu
est
super super
ok bouge pas
rest merci tu peux
couper les caillou c'est joli ça Aué là
c'est super beau
ça
putainele-moi
ouais 1
2 4 5
5 7 8
un peu de cul tout ça ok mais ça je la
Tèche
attends à gauche rien
coupe
voilà c'est joli ça tout
ça
avan dessus là tu veux faire quoi
làattends Vy coupe il y en a plein à
faire il y en a plein il y a celle qui
travers profily
coupe
ou un peu ouv un peu peut-être non voir
d'aut tu
ventrom mais vers le bas to plein de
gensas plein de de gens
quient
me C par du mouvement au télé à mort
c'est ça
j'ai ça vibre pas ça ça VI pas mais ça
ça c'est
moi VI qu'on s l'en quand même qu'on
soit pas paysage un peu
qu'on que tuomes un
peend je
pas l'Impr qu'on est
vraiment
des
elles sont
trop il a pas de machine à
laver
alors attention le reflet
ouais voilà ça c'est joli tu vois çaouis
mais il faut partir d'un plan serré non
non d'accord mais tu vois moi noublie
pas que je fais un film sur du ciel tu
vois sinon non mais justement le plan tu
par serré de ça et c'est jiir c'est joli
d'avoir les gens qui on voit les gens
qui se battent c'est
joli c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon pas monter plus haut c'est bon ça
suffit oh merde j'ai un doigt qui a
bougé
merde de en
CH on reste comme ça c'est bien rester
comme ça reste comme ça c'est bien là
voilà travail sur ce plan
là ils arrivent les autres super regarde
regarde regarde ouais ou ou
oui c'est attends attends mets les
bonnes femmes qui tapent le linge plus
sur la droite de ton écran voilà tu vois
c'est pas pe d'avoir tout ce noir à
droite on s'en fout un peu tu vois ok
voilà tu vois tu recades tout au milieu
de l'image voilà comme ça joli comme ça
encore encore ok voilà tu vois tu peux
resserrer un petit peu si tu veux plus
tu vois resserrer sur le
J
c'est bon que pour le cinéma ça pour la
télé
juste tu peux faire un plan plus serré
sur les j'arrive avait une nana qui est
en mouvement c'est difficile de couper
là jeiv voilà POS son truc OK
par le trop là ça tourne alle on
s'habituer
c'est bien
ça on est plus dans mon film tu vois est
plus dans le dans l'histoire
là je te laisse avec les zbres
ouais oui bien sûr tu peux même te
décaler un peu plus vers ta
droite tu vas faire un plan très serré
dessus voir ça donne tout à
l'heure
allez mon
gars allez allez
allez
voilà
ça Bos ça
B
allez
voilà
voil dirait comme une baleine c'est
marrant bon écoute attend
yautaut
pardonour
japonais
pas tu un spécialiste là
il y a un poisson qui saute et tout quoi
un poisson qui a sauté juste à côté
ouais bon allez c'est pas c'est moi
jeoli ça il y a un
truc regarde euh si tu tu tu t'arrêtes 2
secondes tuas tu vas aller en dessous de
l'hélicoptur beaucoup plus vertical il y
a beaucoup plus de choses tu vas voir
d'accord
moi
moteur com dit moteur en
japonais plus
voil allez chéri ne regarde
pas
ce tas de l à
faire regarde non non non attends
attends attends attends ça va y aller un
patience allez chéri B
VO allez ple qui le de labas ça sera
sublime
j'arrivee début de
l'histoirec
ok term elle regarde
ok encore un coup hop elle
lave allez
coupe tu pour r tu veras qu'àar il a le
rocher et après on finit très très large
il a même C droite et on finit sur les
gens Vy doucement un petit mouvement
quand
mêmeemi tu peux le paster
rentrrière
il y en a plus
après
te paste pas lead reste comme ça
justeessus de quoi ah non c'est bon
c'était l'ombre c'est bon c'est bon elle
est passé
auudessus euh on va aller dans le
contrejour dans laance attends attends
attends va on va dans la brillance on va
dans la brillance attention on va on va
y aller on va y aller on y arrive on y
arrive tu recule un petit peu Fran on y
va voà on va dans laabance attention on
y est
là c'est un pe non elle est
passé Brant c'est joli
ça reculer un peu plus
ouais mais est-ce que ça va être beau
dans la brance c'est pas évident attends
attends
attends ok arrête-toi un moment
ok
c le mec il est dedans tu vas t'attends
pas super c'est super ça ouis c'est
super beau ça
par plus voilà
tu peux te rapprocher un peu dans l'axe
maintenant c'est possible Fran ou on y
va on est loin
est voilà voilà c'est mieux ça voilà VO
ouis j'ai pasardé la brillance si je
décale à droite tu leuras
plus ça donne de la
profondeur s'arrêter par là
regarder tous n regarder
bon ton je sais pas s'il est
là
je t pris je t'en prie c'est bon le
mouvement c'est super dur à
voir oh si j'avais un pied un 33
mon pote j'avais un marteau ou mais un
pied du mal à faire un
pied il
faudraitme quandme 50
m un petit un petit 30 m peut-être
une grue la
selle optiquement c'est quand même très
dur parce qu'on se ramasse
du
comment
mag l'oiseau
merci
devant
plan
que
jeouis
écoute regarde contre
jour
ok voil
bar avec
OK
discute tu V faire après tu
hélicoptère à droite pour voir s' d'aut
dans sont jolis dans
le
[Musique]
allez la
poussière
le truc rigolo
çail juste un peu de
plan
OK et un petit dernier pour le plaisir
oh ça a été court ça a été court il y a
assz il assz il assz pas 10 secondes
he 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
10 1 2 fait 15 3 4 5 6
8 allez coupe B toi un peu sur la droite
Fran
[Musique]
voirour a plein qui arrivent il y en a
plein qui arrivent sur le dos sur la
tête là
j'arve plein qui March et qui descend
vers la
rivière dans contre
jour tu V
partir
vachement descre vers
l'au
tu V voir à gauche tu vas
voir les
autok
bon
écoute regarde
euh faut falloir changer de bande là
maintenant allez cut
vas-y